the jurgen experience there's
like fundamentally there's two ways to
think about uh security one is
like computer security uh this idea that
will somehow make computers secure
we'll put information on the computers
and then we'll prevent other people from
accessing
those computers and that is like a
losing strategy that people have been
losing for
30 years you know uh you information
ends up on a computer somewhere and
it ends up compromised in the end the
other way to think about security is
information security where you secure
the information itself that you don't
have to worry about the security of the
computers you could have some
computers in the cloud somewhere
information's flowing through them and
people can compromise
compromise those things and it doesn't
really matter because the information
itself is encrypted
um and so you know things like sms
you know the imessage cloud backups um
most other messengers facebook messenger
all that stuff you know um they're
relying on this computer security model
um and that
uh ends up disappointing people in the
end
and so you why did you guys create it
like what what was
unsatisfactory about the other options
that were available well because the way
the internet works today
is like insane uh you know that uh
you know fundamentally i feel like um
private communication is
important because i think that change
happens in private um
everything that is fundamentally decent
today
uh started out as something that was a
socially unacceptable idea at the time
you look at things like you know obvious
things abolition of slavery legalization
of
marijuana legalization of same-sex
marriage uh even
you know constructing the declaration of
independence those are all things that
required
a space for people to process ideas
outside the context of
everyday life and um
those spaces don't exist on the internet
today and i think it's kind of crazy the
way the internet works today you know
that like
if you imagined um
you know every moment that you were
talking to somebody in real life there
was somebody there just with a clipboard
a stranger
taking notes about what you said that
would change the character of your
conversations
uh and i think that in some ways
like we're living through a shortage of
brave or bold or courageous ideas in
part because
people don't have the space to process
what's happening in their lives
outside of the context of everyday
interactions that's a really good way to
put it because
you've got to give people a chance to
think things through
but if you do that publicly they're not
going to
they're going to sort of like like
basically what you see
on twitter you know if you stray
from what is considered to be the
acceptable norm
or the current ideology or whatever
whatever you're supposed to whatever
opinions you're supposed to have
on a certain subject you get attacked
ruthlessly so so you see
a lot of self-censorship and you also
see a lot of virtue signaling where
people sort of pretend
that they espouse a certain series of
ideas because that'll get them some
you know some social cred yeah
exactly i think that communication in
those environments is performative you
know you're either performing for
an angry mob you're performing for
advertisers you're performing for
you know the governments that are
watching yeah and i think
also the ideas that make it through are
kind of tainted as a result you know
that like uh
did you watch any of the like the online
hearing stuff that was happening
over covet uh you know where like uh
city councils and stuff were having
their hearings online
no i did not uh it was kind of
interesting to me because it's like um
you know they can't meet in person so
they're doing it online and uh
that means that the public comment
period was also online you know
and so it used to be that like you know
if you go to city council meeting uh
they have a period of public comment
where you know people can just stand up
and
say what you think you know and like
ordinarily it's like oh you gotta go to
city hall you gotta like wait in line
you gotta sit there you know but then
when it's on zoom it's just sort of like
anyone can just show up
right on the zoom you know they just
dial in and they're just like here's
what i think you know
and uh you know it was kind of
interesting because
particularly uh when a lot of the
police brutality still was happening in
los angeles i was i was watching
those city council hearings and you know
people were just like you know
you know they were just calling you to
be like [ __ ] you i yield the rest of my
time
[ __ ] you you know like it was just like
uh really brutal
and uh not undeservingly so and
uh you know what was interesting to me
was just watching
the politicians basically you know who
just had to sit there
and just they were just like take it you
know and it was just like you know you
get three minutes and then there's
someone else you get you know they're
just like
okay and now we'll hear from you know
like and you know watching that you sort
of realize that it's like
um to be a politician you have to just
sort of fundamentally
not really care what people think of you
you know uh
you have to fundamentally uh just be
comfortable
sitting you know and having people yell
at you
you know for three minutes in three
minute increments for an hour whatever
you know
and so it seems like what we've sort of
done is like bred these people who are
willing to do that you know and
in some ways that's like a useful
characteristic but in other ways that's
the characteristic of a psychopath you
know
yes yes and i think you know what we're
seeing is that that also extends
outside of those environments that like
to do anything
ambitious today requires that you just
are comfortable with that kind of um
feedback like trump's tweets if you
watch you know if you look at twitter
and look at any of
trump's tweets when he tweets watch what
people say
it's ruthless they go crazy they go so
hard on him so i'm assuming he doesn't
read them
i'm assuming he just or maybe he does
and just doesn't say anything but
he knows he doesn't go back and forth
with people at least no but and i'm
i i think you know trump is perfectly
capable of just not caring you know just
like people like you know grazing is
just like yo whatever what you know i'm
the best they don't you know
yeah and like that's um you know
that's politics but i think you know the
danger is when that
uh you know to do anything ambitious you
know outside of politics or whatever you
know requires that you're capable of
just
not caring you know what people think
whatever because everything is happening
in public
i think you made a really good point in
that change
comes from people discussing things
privately because
you have to it's a you have to be able
to take a chance
you have to be daring and you have to be
able to confide in people
and you have to be able to say hey um
this is not right and we're going to do
something about it
if you do that publicly the powers that
be that do not want
change in any way shape or form they'll
they'll come down on you
i mean this is essentially what edward
snowden was warning everyone about
when he decided to go public with all
this nsa information
he was saying look this is not what we
signed up for
you like someone's constantly monitoring
your emails constantly listening to
phone calls like this is not
this mass surveillance thing it's very
bad
for just the culture of free expression
just our ability to have ideas and to be
able to share them back and forth and
vet them out
it's very bad yeah yeah i mean i think
when you look at the the history of that
kind of surveillance
there are a few interesting inflection
points you know like at the beginning of
um you know the internet as we know it
in like the early to mid 90s
um there were these like dod efforts to
do
mass surveillance you know um and um
they were sort of open about what they
were doing uh uh
and you know one of them was this
program called total information
awareness
and uh it was they were trying to start
this office i think called the total
awareness office or something within the
dod
and the idea was like they're just going
to like collect information uh on
all americans and everyone's
communication and just stockpile it into
these
uh databases and then they would use
that to you know mine those things for
information
uh it was sort of like you know their
their uh effort to get in on this at the
beginning of the information age
uh and you know it was ridiculous you
know it's like they called it
total information awareness they had a
logo that was like um
you know the pyramid with the eye on top
of it oh yeah this is this is their logo
god it's like the pyramid with the eye
like casting a beam on the earth that
bit of latin there means
knowledge is power oh wow and
interesting this this program was
actually started by uh john poindexter
of all people who was involved in the
iran contra
stuff i think really yeah yeah and he
like went to jail for a second and then
was pardoned or something but
uh so anyway you know they're like
that's so [ __ ] up
these people are in charge of anything i
know but what's also
i just kind of comical is that like they
were like this is what we're going to do
look at how crazy this is like this this
is our plan you know and people were
like uh
i don't think so you know like what year
was this
this is like early mid 90s look at this
authentication
biometric data face fingerprints
gate iris your gate
so they're going to identify people
based on the way they walk
i guess your gate is that specific um
then automated
virtual data repositories privacy and
security
this is fascinating because if you look
at i mean obviously no one
thought of cell phones back then exactly
right this is so this is like kind of
amateurish right so it's like they're
like this is what we're gonna do you
know
and people were like uh i don't think
you know even like congress was like ah
guys i don't think we can like approve
this you know
uh like you need a better logo you know
i can't for sure
but it's just this whole flow chart
is that what this would be what do you
what do you call something like this
what it's called flowchart i guess sort
of
designed to dazzle you and yeah
approving their fun it's like baffling
to figure out what it is like first of
all what are all those little color
tubes
those little ones those little cylinders
these are data silos
oh that's the universal they're all
different colors there's purple ones
what's in the purple data well that's
prince
yeah it's all prince's information but
so okay so that you know
this this stuff all sort of got shut
down right yeah like they're like okay
we can't do this you know
uh and then instead what ended up
happening was like data
naturally accumulated in different
places you know that um you know like
back then if you had been
you know what they were trying to do is
be like our proposal is that everyone
carry a government mandated tracking
device at all times like what do you
guys think you know it'll make us safer
you know
and people are like no i don't think so
you know but instead everyone ended up
just
carrying cell phones at all times which
are tracking your location and reporting
them
into centralized repositories that
government has access to you know and so
uh you know this this sort of like
oblique surveillance infrastructure
ended up emerging
and that was what you know people sort
of knew about but you know we
didn't really know and that's what uh
snowden um
revealed was like uh you know instead we
don't have this instead
it's like all of that all of those
things are happening naturally you know
your you know gate detection fingerprint
you know like all the stuff's happening
naturally it's ending up in these
places and then you know governments
are just going to those places and
getting the information
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background while using other apps
and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience